yo yo yo boys and girls what's shaking
it's your man it's your home slice it's
your ham sandwich it is Jerry and I am
here to talk to you about a movie I saw
actually a while ago now um back in like
mid September early October um like I
said October September the busy month so
I caught this movie and I didn't have a
chance I just sort of Lost in the
shuffle of recording but I'm here now so
here we go um I recently saw a film
called horns that some of you may have
heard of um it's based on Joe Hills and
Joe Hill as some of you might know is
Stephen King's son and uh this is a
movie starring Daniel Radcliffe breaking
that mold to Harry Potter it's also
directed by a guy I very much admire
these days uh named Alex Aza Alexander
Aza um who did such things as the remake
of The Hills Have Eyes which I think is
great um Piranha 3D which I have yet to
see cuz I'm a bad person he produced and
co-wrote the remake of maniac last year
which I really love among other you know
various films and uh I'm a big fan of
this guy's work so I was very excited to
check this out and this is a quirky
movie I didn't really quite know what it
was about I saw the trailer maybe once
and that got me really excited and going
in I didn't really know a lot of the
particulars of the story other than it
was about this young man whose fiance
was murdered and obviously he's blamed
for it and it's sort of a question as to
whether he did it or not and somewhere
along the way he starts to sprout horns
and then people start behaving very
strangely and so this movie I think is
very cool I will say this it is an
uneven movie however I think that when
it's good it is really good and there
are a lot of great performances in it
there are a lot of people in this movie
that you'll recognize So Daniel
Radcliffe is obviously in this movie
he's the protagonist um and then you
also have um Juno Temple who plays his
uh fiance the sort of figure at the
center of a lot of the trouble and the
turmoil in this story and you have his
brother played by Joe Anderson who's an
actor I love uh he's great in the
crazies he's great in the gray uh he's
great pretty much every time I've seen
him pop up I'm really happy to see him
getting more work Max Mela as one of his
childhood friends and that's sort of a
thing that figures heavily into this
movie as well um James Remar is his
father Kathleen quinlon is his mom um
you also have David Morris in it you
have Heather Graham in a small part
which I thought was kind of cool because
it's not super inyour face like oh
Heather Graham is here and it's not a
huge character but she does get to have
a lot of fun and I was happy to see her
in a movie again um especially just in a
supporting role like this cuz you know I
get the sense of a lot of people might
have turned something like that down um
but I'm glad she's here and I'm also
happy to see Kelly Garner again you know
I've always had a bit of a a celebrity
crush on Kelly Garner and I'm happy to
see her in this movie and I think she's
really good too so there are a lot of
good and interesting performances and I
have to imagine that this was a fun
movie to act in because part of the deal
with the horns is they bring out the
sort of hidden sides of people the
secrets because there's a lot about
secrets and about who's hiding what in
this movie movie and why so everybody
gets to play their regular daily life
version of their character and then they
also get to play sort of strange and
twisted version saying all the things
you would never dream of saying to
somebody um and that's part of the fun
of this movie it's a very quirky film
it's very strange and while you know not
every moment is pitched perfect there
are a lot of good moments and Daniel
Radcliffe does a good job of carrying
most of the film there's some really
beautiful cinematography in here
especially in the flashbacks and whatnot
how things are captured and what I
thought was cool was you have this sort
of grinning Twisted mystery in the
present day but you also have these
flashbacks that kind of hearken back to
things like Stand By Me or or or The
Goonies in a way where it's like you
know your Youth and and your friends
growing up and the things you would do
together the trouble you would get in
and there are interludes there are
flashback sequences that hearken back to
those kinds of movies and that was just
sort of a a nice thing you know it made
me feel warm watching those there's a a
lot of emotion here in various forms and
there's a lot of you know really mean
little set pieces as well you know it's
a very interesting little Dark Fantasy
in a lot of ways they use their effects
well you know there's a there's a mix of
practical effects work and CG work and
they they do seem to mix them well and
like I said it is something of an uneven
movie I will give it that there are
certain Pace issues certain scenes that
don't play as well as others do and
there are certain times where you you
sort of feel like could have used a
better take here and there and I've
generally heard tell that it doesn't
quite get into all the implications that
the book does but I do think it is
successful because when it's good I
think it's really good when you know
Alex AA gets a chance to jump off the
leash and really do his thing it's great
there's one particularly crazy drug trip
sequence that's awesome um so this movie
does go a lot of places and it does
commit to itself especially when things
get sort of out of hand and whatnot um
and as a mystery I mean I've heard some
people say that they found it vaguely
predictable and I can see that but just
the same I do think it works I do think
um again I haven't read the book so I'm
probably not biased in that way but I do
like what's going on here and I mean
it's interesting to see what Alex AA
does with with a story that requires a
little more restraint for a lot of it
and it makes those moments where he can
jump off the leash that much more um fun
and enjoyable I also really appreciate
the sort of small town vibe in this
movie you it takes place in sort of a
small coastal town you know with a lot
of greenery and Forest and I really do
appreciate just that aesthetic that
environment you know it does feel very
small town and there are also some
really cool music choices in here
because you know part of the
relationship between Daniel Radcliffe
character and the Juno Temple Temple
character is their love of music and
whatnot and there are a lot of great
little heartfelt moments in here it's
not always quite as great as you get the
sense that it could have been but there
is some really good stuff at work here
and it is a really cool little Dark
Twisted Fantasy fairy tale thing so um
I'm generally feeling positive about
this movie I like all the people
involved I like the performances for the
most part um I thought the story and the
humor was really cool so yeah even if
it's a bit uneven it's still a good time
and I still quite uh enjoyed myself you
know maybe check it out when it when it
hits DVD since it's probably not in the
theater anymore um but there is some
really beautiful stuff hidden in this
movie and there is some very uh warm and
also some very sort of Darkly funny
stuff hidden in this movie so um it's
it's a bit Scrappy but I I liked it so
yeah that's that's horns that was a
movie I I was actually quite excited for
recently so I'm interested to see how
it'll play on a second go around so if
you've seen it what did you think you
want to share some thoughts hit up the
comment section like And subscribe and
all that jazz be kind to your
compatriots writing on the wall there
and um uh what's your favorite
recent Daniel Radcliffe movie and what
would you like to see him do next
because you know it's got to be hard uh
you know breaking out of the Harry
Potter mold after eight films and I
think he he's doing a decent job of that
so um yeah what do you think uh that's
it for now horns is the film Alex AA
till next time I am Jerry
cheers